the Chinese Premiere Lee kiang is
leading a delegation to Germany meant to
increase economic ties the talks between
Lee and Chancellor Olaf Schultz will be
joined by ministers from both countries
climate change is set to be the main
focus and Berlin is Seeking a larger
role in China's electric vehicle Market
but also wants to discourage Beijing
from supporting Russia in its war in
Ukraine joining me from Berlin is that
fast and so Steph tell us more about
what's on the agenda for this first
consultative meeting in three years
well the Chinese Crimea was just
welcomed with military honors here at
the chancellery in Berlin and now the
two leaders all of Shoals a German
chancellor and leechang will have these
bilateral talks before going into the
seventh consultative meeting it's the
first time in three years that both
delegations are meeting here and it's an
interesting fact that Germany actually
asked the Chinese not to bring the usual
large delegation of Ministers of 20
ministers so they basically have slimmed
down this a little bit and this also
shows how Germany actually has been
struggling with its relationship with
its largest trading partner China China
especially the the German companies the
car makers are very keen on continuing
their business of course in China
they're Keen to get into this Electric
market to give you one example
Volkswagen one of the largest car makers
has 38 of its cars is sold in China so
it's it's a balancing act that's been
described the meeting today so there
will be a lot on the agenda as you said
climate change the role China can play
in a combating climate change that's one
of the items that shows definitely wants
to talk about yeah and stuff Schultz has
spoken about de-risking from China what
does he mean by that and will this be
one of the topics of discussion
well that's interesting after the US
came up with the decoupling were
decoupling from China Charles said no we
don't want decoupling we want de-risking
and that's also something the G7 uh made
leaders have adopted and what it means
exactly we don't know at this stage does
it mean that uh uh critical
infrastructure can't be allowed into
Germany anymore I mean Chinese
investment in critical infrastructure
like what happened for example with the
Hamburg Port just a few months ago China
bought a big stake in the Hamburg port
and that was heavily criticized of
course Germany has this experience of
being too dependent on Russia at least
that's what Germany experienced after
the invasion in Ukraine so now they
don't want to make the same mistake
again but the stakes in China are a lot
higher as the stakes were in Russia so
that's going to be a very complicated
issue and I'm not sure if Shoals is
going to even mention the word dear
risking today okay you'll keep us across
the story for the time being thank you
so much that passing for that update
from Berlin